[Music]
we're all familiar with the legendary
ideal of outlaws like
robin hood living on the outskirts of
english society
robbing from the wealthy and giving to
the poor based on such tales one might
assume that being an outlaw in the
medieval era was synonymous with being a
criminal
but this is far from the case being an
outlaw was terrifying because you were
literally declared to be outside
the protection of the law in short if
you were an outlaw and someone were to
murder you that person wouldn't face
legal consequences
the same thing goes for any other crime
you can think of
possessions money and any land you once
owned also became
forfeit the moment you were declared an
outlaw it was almost like the purge but
it only applied
to you being declared a felon
in most countries today is much
different committing a serious offense
in most modern nations might result in a
lengthy prison sentence
but the system of laws still
theoretically applies to you
just because you're on trial for robbery
for example
it wouldn't be legally permissible for
someone to break into the courthouse and
shoot you with an arrow to put it
bluntly
but in medieval europe if you were an
outlaw you had
no such right to safety examining the
text of the medieval common law of
england
a word about lorry made with respect to
you
kaput lupinum literally meaning let his
be
a wolf's head legally speaking the term
essentially equates you with a wolf or
any other wild beast in the eyes of the
law it's a roundabout way of indicating
anyone who felt keen to hunt you down as
if you were an animal
would face no punishment for it indeed
there was often some reward
either social or economic for doing so
but outlaws weren't just hunted by
random citizens
as fugitives outlaws were pursued by
county sheriffs and other forms of
feudal law enforcement which were
notoriously brutal
furthermore it was actually illegal for
anyone
even family members to give you aid
including basic necessities like food
and shelter
once a word of out lorry had been
declared life was
extremely rough the crazy history of
outlawy extends all the way back to
ancient roman laws of exile
the penalty was then referred to as
homosacchar latin for
the accursed man and meant as with
medieval society the unlucky individual
was forced from civilization and
deprived of all civic rights
exile also included the related
punishment of aqua
at igni interdictus literally
translating as
to forbid water and fire this opposing
addendum meant what it implies codifying
the illegality of providing outlaws with
basic necessities
pretty similar to medieval laws around
offering aid
examining the history of outlawary and
other countries in early germanic law
the death penalty is
notably absent altogether with being
made an outlaw the most severe
punishment
since the label was so dangerous this
makes a grim amount of sense
being made an outlaw was essentially a
fate worse than death
much later in the 16th century the
german concept of
vogel fry took on a similar meaning the
denotation of the term is similar to
free as a bird which began as a positive
description implying independence
with time however being a vogel fry
meant you had the same
legal rights as a bird or beast due to
criminal actions
and as with other cultures meant your
days were numbered
exactly what constitutes a crime serious
enough to be made in outlaw depended on
the culture and time period with
everything from
robbery to murder to not showing up for
court when summoned being listed as
examples
the legendary outlaw of english folklore
robin hood
might have certainly faced such a
punishment were he a real historical
figure in 13th or 14th century ce
making the character a bit more hardcore
than he's often remembered
a notable historic outlaw is norse
warrior eric the red
who is exiled in 982 ce for killing
another member of his community
not interested in sticking around to be
potentially killed while an outlaw he
sailed north and might have helped
discover
greenland pretty interesting stuff
going full circle and returning to
english common law the outlaw punishment
is thankfully no longer in effect in the
modern day
funnily enough though the law wasn't
officially abolished in england until as
late as 1938
although the concept was already
obsolete and wasn't actually being used
still there's something interesting
about the fact that outlaw punishment
technically survived all the way up
until the invention of the car
were the punishment about lorry brought
back today it would
be extremely terrifying in our modern
society so we can all be glad we don't
live
in the medieval era and that's where a
discussion of ancient outlaws reaches
its conclusion
i hope you enjoyed learning about a law
i think we can all agree
wouldn't be too nice to have applied to
you please consider subscribing and
leaving this video a like if you enjoyed
the content
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you